hey Senna files this is our list of the
top five films to see at the 2014
Melbourne International Film Festival
number five
electric boogaloo the wild untold story
of Canon films this is the latest
documentary by Marc Hartley the man who
previously delivered not quite Hollywood
and machete maidens unleashed electric
Boogaloo concludes Hartley's trilogy
exploring exploitation cinema
specifically following the account of
man ahem Golan and Yoram Globus as they
pitch on repeat house cannon films on
the map the documentary will have its
world premiere at Melbourne number four
it follows a high school girls boyfriend
is murdered after they have sex for the
first time and she becomes the next in
line for the curse the only way to pass
it on is to get it on with someone new
after making waves that this year's can
Film Festival it follows has a
reputation that precedes itself not just
for its intriguing premise but also for
scaring the pants off festival goers
number three are 100 a furniture
salesman looks to spice up his life by
joining an S&M Club where he must remain
a member for an entire year this means
that any given moment a group of
dominatrices have the right to beat him
up the film's title is a play on the
Japanese rating system alluding that the
film is not suitable for anybody under
100 years old this baddie darks the
teracle comedy comes to us from
writer-director Hitoshi Matsumoto who
previously gave us big man Japan and
symbol number two jaja a father and
daughter journey from Denmark to an
unknown desert that exists in a realm
beyond the confines of civilization jaja
is the latest film from Argentinian
writer director lisandro alonso it stars
Viggo Mortensen an ever unpredictable
actor in his first Danish speaking role
jaja was also met with praise at can
where it won an International Federation
of film critics prize number one the
Kingdom of Dreams and madness
next year Studio Ghibli celebrates its
30th anniversary
the legendary animation house was
founded by Hayao Miyazaki I saw Takahata
and producer Toshio Suzuki Miyazaki and
Takahata have supposedly made their
final films this documentary offers
unprecedented access to see how the
studio turned up one masterpiece after
another and what its future might be the
Kingdom of Dreams the madness open
Japan last year but this is one of the
first opportunities for the rest of the
world to see it those are our top five
films to see at the 2014 Melbourne
International Film Festival what films
are you most excited for let us know in
the comments below
and keep a tab open on the movie clips
in D channel for all your film festival
needs thanks for watching
you